[Music]
[Applause]
first up is a commercial that I think
chooses it well a very confusing way to
promote its product I found this to be a
confusing commercial okay yeah take a
look beautiful fashion dangerous
[Music]
none of these people will ever have sex
with you so go ahead and eat your
Beefaroni
Beefaroni about the food is your life
will ever get I was shocked when I found
that was a Beefaroni oh wow I did not
see that really yeah but you know makes
you think it's terrific that's a great
company you know I thought Allegra was a
rather harmless allergy pill but then I
saw this latest ad and man did it
changed my mind
before Allegra my allergy medicine made
me drowsy after Allegra I'm back in the
game before Allegra
I waited hours for my medicine to work
after Allegra I get fast relief before
Allegra allergies made me miserable
after Allegra around me again
my crap combines 24 hours
with the power to relieve your toughest
symptoms side effects include cross
dressing now our next step is one of
those late-night infomercials now I know
these things can be formulaic but I
think the people who put this ad
together were asleep at the switch I
just don't think they were paying
attention
take a look there's a new breakthrough
for men experiencing hair loss
introducing the new Xtreme laser comb
from Hair Club it's quick easy and
affordable I'm very excited about my
hair getting my hair back was the best
thing that ever happened to me
I added 5 inches to my penis in only
four days and then you probably want to
hand down because the actions down here
know about this number to get more
information on the Xtreme laser comb and
get your hair back what the laser comb
locations nationwide there's a hair Club
center near you I'm in the wrong
commercial why do you guys put me on a
rotating platform this is very
disorienting and unnecessary Hair Club
call now for your free info kit and free
hair analysis so will you guys just send
me a laser comb and I'll try it out that
how this work
[Applause]
[Music]
when he continued to participate in that
act and then why did they air it these
are all questions I have that guy looks
like he's got some time on his hands up
next is an ad for a famous brand of
frozen fish with a very familiar mascot
I just found the way that they updated
this character a little off-putting try
Gorton's grilled tilapia flame grilled
and seasoned with real herbs and spices
it's 80 calories that sizzle good don't
worry about my pending trial for public
urination you shouldn't bring it up I
didn't even know about I really
shouldn't finally an ad for Audi now
this car ad starts out very cute but
then what takes a turn is evidence that
P was my dad's a space alien he speaks
our language
he drinks green stuff he says he's from
Albuquerque I'm not buying it let me
just look at him
and one more thing he has a spaceship
[Music]
my dad's an Aryan and that's why I must
kill daddy
[Applause]
[Music]
and that's why I must kill daddy the
greatest catch line ever for a product
we can take a break